the Caballeros is probably much better
known than saludos amigos but be fair
they're not that much different true and
comparing the two that does seem to be a
lot more passion thrown into this one
it's longer there's more energy and as
far as their basic cartoon animation
goes this is some of their best I mean
the motion and the line work just leaps
off the screen sometimes look at how
fast they're going
but much like saludos amigos
there isn't really a story oh well in
about as much as it's just Donald
opening some presents yeah that's the
story isn't every riveting he gets a
package on his birthday which it turns
out is Friday the 13th that you didn't
know that and each present it turns out
is a presentation on some place he's
never been to before I like the last
film they're shorts there's songs
there's down duck acting like Donald
Duck and at first I was kind of getting
into it I was kind of enjoying all the
randomness mixed in with the music and
like I said that really fast-paced
animation and the stories were a lot
more memorable - there's one about a
penguin trying to get to warmer climate
another one about a burro who can fly
but then the story sort of stopped and
we get that green parrot again him and
Donald look around Brazil a bit they
dance they sing they have fun I guess
and then he opens the last package and
we have that wood pecker thing I'm not
sure what he is but he comes out to sing
about Mexico and literally the last
third of this movie is just Donald
trying to get laid every time you see
him he's fawning over a woman or women
and just trying to get somebody to
tickle his tail feathers two-thirds of
the movie is pretty much like just being
at a party which at first sounds awesome
but at some point you kind of want to
leave that party and find something else
or talk to somebody or take a breather
or I don't know but there's only so long
you can do it and that's the problem
with this film after a while it gets
tiring the animation continues to
impress as well as some really good
live-action mixing but you're just sort
of watching people dance most of the
time and for a few minutes it's fine
but for a whole second half of a movie
it gets pretty old pretty fast then we
just cut to the three of them acting
goofy and abstract land again they jump
around shoot some guns fire off some
fireworks and that's it that's the movie
um fun there's a lot of things I really
like about this film I like a lot of the
scenes I like a lot of the animations
and the short stories which is why I
hate it so much when I see it all
together because it suddenly becomes
boring this is one of those movies where
on the Disney Channel they would shop it
up and they would just show it as little
shorts on their cartoon shows and that's
really where it belongs I can't see this
really functioning as a film
maybe if they went for more of a cirque
du soleil thing or kept a little bit
more focus or even lack of focus just
something that went all the way here it
seems like they kind of want to do short
stories and now they kind of want to do
it as one long party and now they kinda
wanna make it educational but now they
kind of want to make it silly the only
thing that's consistently good as I said
before is the animation which is really
stylized and fun but for me I don't
think that holds the film if you want to
see it just for the motion and the cool
drawings I'd say maybe check it out but
even then that's a big maybe there's
other Disney film that do animation
better then they have good story and
characters to go along with it so I
probably just recommend those but if
you're curious enough it does have some
good moments take that for what it's
worth
you